die korona krise am höhepunkt täglich
neue traurige rekordzahlen in den
krankenhäusern
am klinikum fulda ist die kurve die
intensivstation voll belegt die
belastung für pfleger und ärzte hoch
bild durfte sie tag und nacht begleiten
oberarzt dr christoph schmidt ist es
gewohnt tragödien auf der
intensivstation zu erleben heute nicht
okay das ist gut den patienten die nicht
in gestern vorgestellt haben geht es
weiterhin gut
der kommt mit acht litern nasen brille
komplett zu recht frühstückt jetzt
gerade mithilfe genau könnte wirklich
verlegt werden
sie melden sich bei mir danke tschüss
ich denke dass wir heute jetzt mal hier
die intensivstation verlassen können und
dann geht es weiter aufwärtsgehe
aber sie werden noch ein paar wochen
brauchen die zeit müssen sie sich lassen
haben sie denn aktuell irgendwelche
beschwerden
die luft ist noch knapp wahrscheinlich
und das mit den händen habe ich gehört
das ist so ein leichter nerven schaden
durch die erkrankung aber sie dürfen
davon ausgehen dass der sich erholen
wird
werner sauer wird seit sechs wochen
wegen kubi 19 behandelt eröffnet
inzwischen wieder selbst bekommt nur
noch sauerstoff zur unterstützung die
luft reicht heute sogar für ein kurzes
telefonat mit seiner frau
es geht bergauf seine verlegung wird
höchste zeit für wache patienten kann
die intensivstationen gerade ohne besuch
wie der jetzigen corona krise zu einer
emotionalen hölle werden
herr sauer war ist mittlerweile soweit
dass er natürlich die behandlung seiner
mitpatienten zum teil mitbekommen hat
und jetzt praktisch erlebt was mit ihm
mutmaßlich in der phase als er
geschlafen hat und dass eben natürlich
nicht mitbekommen hat
geschehen ist so dass er sich neben der
tatsache dass er weiß dass er schwer
erkrankt war natürlich jetzt auch mit
den mit dem thema der behandlung dieser
erkrankung zunehmend auseinander setzen
musste und das müssen wir jetzt einfach
unterbinden und wir freuen uns dass er
sich so erholt hat dass er die station
verlassen kann
von der intensivstation geht es auf die
normalstation zwei pflegerinnen holen
werner sauer ab doch bevor er die kogit
abteilung des klinikums verlässt hat er
noch eine botschaft an all diejenigen
die das virus nicht ernst nehmen aber er
blickt positiv in die zukunft
schon zu sagen
rainer lang genug
max raabe
werner sauer hat es geschafft das team
der intensivstation am klinikum fulda
tut alles menschenmögliche damit ihn
viele gucken 19 patienten folgen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren